there was a and i say that because there
was a controversial poll online
where it said that the least desired man
when it comes to the dating market is an
asian man yeah yes i heard that east
asian man data well dating app data um
yeah it's like indian i'm pretty sure
but no number one is white number two is
black um but black is like
moving up according to like dating app
data oh wow cause that's how you can get
the most honest feedback you know what
it is for women the most desired i want
to see if you guys guess it for women
yeah the most desires yeah like the most
right to south american women um that's
weird it's asian
the most is that women are asian like
they're the most swept right on dating
apps elsewhere mm-hmm
swept black
black women yeah
because there because there was there
was an article i was reading i think it
was on vice and they were saying um you
know racism shows itself in the dayton
app market but i don't think it's
necessarily racism i just think people
have got preferences
i mean i think it goes back to like size
at least in the u.s
size yeah like
like
no no like like again black women are
more obese in the u.s
no i don't think it's that because at a
certain point
i think
i don't know about you guys but i like i
like my woman to have some features on
them that you know show they're a woman
so
what does that mean right but like by
and large you're an exception you're not
the rule like you you might you may
prefer like curvier or bigger women but
like by and large when a man gets money
what does he do he gets he gets a bad
little like model yeah
he doesn't go and get lizzo yeah i'm not
saying that
my
my type is like super curvy yeah i guess
more to what i'm your type is super
curvy women no
um more to my point is that
it it's about liking a woman i feel like
as a black guy like a woman who has
features like
when i think about what i like to do
whether it's salsa whether i'm like
carnival
you know i want someone who's able to
move who can who can move their hips
they need to have hips to kind of do
that you know it's things like that
where
to be honest
i just
that's what i'm i'm kind of thinking of
so if i'm on a dating app or if when i
was
past tense
um
i don't know i felt like
sometimes black women wouldn't really
reply you know
at a certain point
it's like you you swipe on who you feel
like you'd get a response from it's no
longer about
you know what what you like because
on on dating that's for sure one what
you like does not always swipe back so
it's a bit of a when they why'd you
think they wouldn't reply
no girls don't reply most of the time
like it
does it doesn't really matter like
maybe it's just me maybe i was a bit
unfortunate and i'm i'm not i'm not that
well endowed in in the facial features
but honestly
no
this is a family show
no honest but yeah no they
normally don't really reply to too tough
and i would come with some spicy lines
you know what i'm saying but it
really had game yeah yo i'm telling you
i can drop game man
but no
it didn't really matter why i did or
said
sometimes you just wouldn't get nothing
back
and even if you did it wouldn't go
nowhere